we are minority investors in companies
that are between 3 and 100 million a
year and so we take minority Stakes
typically between 20 and 33 of those
businesses depending on the business
we're either Investing For Cash Flow for
some sort of return or we're reinvesting
cash into the business so that we can
eventually sell it later it really just
depends on the business is it a
long-term hold is it like a Fix and Flip
it just depends on the business but
typically we are minority investors in
those companies and we bring a lot of
Hands-On help to grow the business and
get the founder some sort of cash no
cash exchanges hands us to the founder
because we're either investing into the
business so that it can grow or we're
doing something in kind because it's
based on the amount of value that we're
going to provide